Once, when I was in college, I saw a cockroach
crawl out of the sink drain in my dorm.
Like, out of the depths of the sewer, and
into my dorm room.
I have never been the same.
Ever.
But it turns out, roaches could do some good
in the world because their genetic code, which
was recently fully sequenced, provides surprising
insight into their seemingly eternal survival.
Now we have a better idea of just why cockroaches
are so freaking hard to kill: THEY’RE EVOLVING.
Not only can cockroaches multiply seemingly
infinitely, regenerate from traumatizing wounds,
fit into any crevice, survive incredibly forceful
physical extermination, evolve to evade chemical
apocalypse...but despite their inherent gross
factor, they may also hold an important key
to help us understand how to improve our own
biology.
Researchers at the Chinese Academy of Sciences
have sequenced the entire genome of the American
cockroach for the first time ever, and their
genome is surprisingly huge.
The research team found genes indicating that
when under stress, female cockroaches can
lay unfertilized eggs that will still hatch
due to parthenogenesis--which is quite literally
virgin birth.
(This gives a whole new meaning to, “Jesus,
cockroaches!”)
This is observed in other insects too, like
certain kinds of wasps, bees and ants, as
well as some reptiles, and only requires one
parent’s genetic code.
No sex required.
Just crazy science coolness.
This reproductive method means that when mom
detects an environment she suspects may not
allow her to live much longer, she’ll just
plop down some ready-made eggs to make sure
her genes survive.
You may think you’ve killed one cockroach,
but unbeknownst to you, there are more spawning
elsewhere….
Additionally, the research team uncovered
the genes and genetic regulation pathways
responsible for the cockroach’s ability
to regenerate limbs.
Offshoots of this research have lead to the
development of a drug in China that’s based
on an ethanol found in cockroaches, and is
being touted as potentially useful in human
medicine for wound healing and tissue repair.
They also identified the genes responsible
for in-body anti-microbial production, which
keeps cockroaches safe while they’re rooting
around in the sewage and trash.
This could be part of the reason that cockroaches
have a tendency to become resistant to our
extermination methods.
While the genome that was recently sequenced
is that of the American cockroach, other research
has indicated that its cousin the German cockroach
has evolved to dislike the taste of the poison
bait we’ve been putting out to kill it--instead
of tasting irresistibly sweet, it now tastes
bitter to them, and they avoid it, so we’re
having a hard time finding something that
could kill it.
Now that we have a better understand the cockroach
genome, we might be able to kill them more
effectively which is something we’d like
to do because they’re gross and they spread
plague.
No seriously, they carry hella disease.
But, another point in the cockroach’s favor,
they can help us improve our robotics.
These tiny bugs can withstand over 900 times
their body weight in crushing force, and are
able to squeeze into so many places (LIKE
DORM ROOMS) by compressing themselves to almost
a third of their full size.
Both of these superpowers are due to their
exoskeleton, which is hard but also “jointed”
and flexible.
Experts say that if we could make bots with
these features, we could revolutionize fields
like search and rescue, with the bots able
to access areas of disaster zones that humans
and other traditional search animals could
never penetrate.
There’s still a long way to go in this area
of research, but it’s going to be interesting
to see what we can learn from animals like
this, and what we can take from their genetic
mechanisms to use for our own benefit.
For more exciting facts about our arthropod
friends, make sure you subscribe, and check
out this video on the bugs that may be in
your food.
Turns out, people who seem allergic to chocolate
or coffee may just be reacting to the pieces
of cockroach that find their way in there
during the manufacturing process.
Yup, I just ruined everything.
Thank for watching!